>>Lisa: I definitely think that the
digital media provides a different
way of looking at the content.
The thing that I love the
most about the Puzzle Maker
and my algebra students especially
just loved was, we were talking
about parabolas and we were
talking about vertical motion
and then we built it and they got
to go in the game and experience it.
Because you talk about,
"Oh, we're throwing the ball
or we're bouncing off the thing."
Well, you go into the Puzzle Maker,
you jump off the aerial faith plate
and it was neat for them
to actually experience how
that changes the motion virtually.
>>Joshua: Portal 2 is basically a
game-based really simple premise.
It's this idea that you can do
this impossible thing in our world,
which is open a hole in space
in one place and another,
and if I go in one hole,
I'll come out the other one.
That world fit really
well into a space
where you could actually have an
editor and make your own puzzles
so that, you know, you
weren't just being challenged
by what we could create.
You could actually
create your own challenges
and you could share
them with friends.
So the Puzzle Maker is really all
about that, giving people that chance
to put on the hat of a designer,
sit down and try their hand
at what they can come up with.
>>Yasser: I think that what
makes an authentic experience is
that it's really open.
We didn't really frame the problem,
other than giving you a set of rules
for how these items interact.
It really is kind of
an open play space.
>>Student: I think the best thing
about working with Portal 2 is
that you can just do what you want
and the community test
chambers are really awesome,
because it's just your
design that you can play,
instead of playing the levels
that are there for you.
>>Yasser: We kind of sense that
people are really interested in
and have started talking
about puzzle craft itself.
We've kind of been thinking
about features that can kind
of help people learn from each
other, and to take the process we go
through of creating something,
play testing it, iterating on that
and then building that
into the game itself,
so that process becomes
a fun, natural extension
of learning how to create puzzles.
>>Joshua: If we think about what
worked with the Puzzle Maker
and what didn't, I think what felt
like we got right was the kind
of lowering that bar
to entry for people.
A week after we released
it, we had like a hundred
and twenty thousand
submissions, which is well
and above anything we
would have expected.
And so I think it was
exciting, not just to see
that many people making maps, but
that many people sharing their maps,
because I think making a map is
one thing, but actually putting it
out there for everybody
else is another.
>>Leslie: When you are
able to, within seconds,
transfer from building the
puzzle with the different assets
in the palette, to actually
playing the level you just created,
you are in the video game playing
it, that is an unbelievable sense
of accomplishment for a young person.
The puzzle maker has a threshold
that's so low for someone to just try
to put in some effort that what
comes out of it feels really good.
>>Yasser: Over time,
I think my concept
of where games provide
value has kind of shifted.
Now I kind of think of it more
as instilling a useful
pattern of learning.
So rather than presenting the
information and then challenging
and then testing, I think it's
more interesting to present a place
where kids can practice kind
of the love of learning,
kind of show them how once
they've kind of attained agency
in that skill set, they can
then create and share and kind
of loop back in a way that's
kind of relevant to their peers.
>>Lisa: Learning is enhanced
when students are engaged.
The kids that are engaged come at
it from a different perspective
with a different excitement
and I think a different type
of retention and ability to apply it.